So there is no doubt
the decision to indict
has elicited
a strong reaction
across the political spectrum.
New CNN polling shows many Americans
believe politics played
at least some role in the decision
to indict Donald Trump.
Take a look at this.
52% say politics played a major role.
And you see. 23% say a minor role.
Some think no role
and there's also an element of people
still they really are not sure.
CNN's Jeff Zeleny joins
us now for much more on this.
Jeff, many people think people
that politics
played some role in this indictment,
but how many people,
how many people
that were polled
actually approve of the indictment?
This is so interesting.
Of course, you cannot divorce politics
from any of this
because we were talking about
the former president
here, who,
of course, is a current candidate
for the White House.
But when you look at the findings
of our new poll, take a look at this.
60% of Americans,
some six in ten of Americans support
the overall indictment here.
And 40% are against it.
That's largely driven by
sort of
some common views from Republicans.
Of course, they're opposed
Democrats support,
but independents largely
follow this rule.
So that is so interesting.
That.
60% support
and we should be clear,
we do not know exactly
what is in the indictment.
This is just based on the broad
confines of a familiar storyline
of a hush money payment
that we've been talking about
for more than six years now.
So six in ten Americans support that.
But there is so much
more interesting findings
in our poll
this morning that
really speaks
to the dynamic of the politics
going into this, Kate.
And one thing we see is the one thing
maybe the
the only unsurprising thing in
this is that
it shows that the nation is remains
so divided,
especially when it comes to Donald Trump.
But what
what is it
what are you seeing in this poll
in terms of the overall impact,
the impact on the country,
the impact on democracy?
We should talk about the historic
nature of this. Yes.
You know,
this is a
really run of the mill indictment,
but a former president has never been
indicted and arraigned.
So the next 48 hours
are going to see something in the country
we have never seen before.
So when you talk about democracy,
take a look at these numbers.
What do you think about the strength
of democracy?
And 31% of Americans
say that it strengthens.
31% say it weakens.
23%, it has no effect at all.
So divided Americans
clearly divided among party lines
and familiar lines on this.
But this is a historic proceeding.
No question.
So we cannot
not take stock of all of that.
But there is no doubt as we go forward
here, democracy is at the core of this.
And the
he obviously has other
cases pending in Georgia
and in federal court as well.
So this is something
that will be a through line
of all this conversation today, Kate.
That's that is and that is a great point.
It's good to see you, Jeff.
Thank you so much.
CNN's Chris Cornell is outside
the court in New York City for us.
Corrupt officials in New York
are set to make a public announcement
that we're just hearing the commissioner
and the mayor.
What are you learning
Yes, Sara, that's right.
So it just fell at noon Eastern.
New York City mayor
and the
NYPD commissioner
are expected
to make an announcement
to address the public
about the security measures
that are in place
for Trump's arraignment tomorrow.
Now, sources tell bringing
Grasp that there are no credible threats
against the courthouse or in the area
and there's no threat of disrupting
But they will give the public
a briefing of what to expect
now behind the scenes.
There's a lot that's also happening.
There's restrictions
on the 15th floor in the courthouse
behind me over my shoulder.
That is where the former president
will be arraigned,
come in, self surrender midday.
And they were speeding up this process.
He may or may not have a mug shot taken.
There are questions about that.
He's likely to be fingerprinted
and then he will
walk down a public hallway
where other defendants,
everyone from drug dealers
to his former chief financial officer
and go into the courtroom
and face the judge,
that's when the judge
will ask him to enter a plea.
And Trump's attorneys
say that he will plead not guilty.
From there,
Trump is expected
to head back to the airport
and then back to Mar
a Lago, where he said
he will address the nation at eight 15.
Sara
arraignments a regular course of business
for the courts, but not this one.
Can you give us a sense of what Trump's
legal team has been saying?
They have done a media blitz over
the last few days.
Yeah, they certainly have.
And I mean, their main point here
is that they are going to look
for every possible way
to launch a legal challenge in this case
put going ahead
that they're putting forward
an aggressive posture.
Now, one thing
that one of Trump's attorneys,
Joe Tacopina,
he was on CNN yesterday
and saying, you know, just how aggressive
they're going to take this.
Take a listen.
We will take the indictment.
We will dissect it.
The team will look at every every
potential issue
that we will be able to challenge
and we will challenge.
And, of course,
I very much anticipate
a motion to dismiss coming
because there's no law that fits this
at all.
So they're looking to take a bunch of
legal angles here.
Motions to dismiss,
also possibly challenging
the statute of limitations in this case.
So what other matters?
Now, the one thing, though, is
that those motions
will all happen a bit down the road
because we've yet to see
what the specific charges
are in this indictment.
And CNN
and other media organizations
have asked the judge to unseal that.
The judge just has a deadline
for both sides that Trump and the D.A.
to respond at 1 p.m..
And we could see these specific charges
and the indictment unsealed later today.
Sara, Kara Scannell, thank you.
Outside of the court there in New York.
I want to bring in CNN
national correspondent Kristen Holmes.
You are in West Palm Beach, Florida,
as we can see
with the wind and the water behind you.
The president is set to take off
in, I think, less than an hour.
What are you learning about his plan?
Sara?
That's absolutely right.
So we are waiting to see him
leave his Mar a Lago home.
He will be traveling
with a small group of aides,
including his top campaign advisors,
Susie Wiles and Chris loss of Aida.
They will be traveling
by motorcade to the airport,
which is close by,
and then flying into LaGuardia
on Trump's private plane.
And they are expected
to land around 3:00.
Then we are told
Trump will go to Trump Tower.
And I was actually just told by a source
that he is likely
to meet with his lawyers
while he is in Trump Tower.
He will spend the night there before
heading to the courthouse on Tuesday.
Now, as you noted and as Kara noted,
he will come back almost immediately
after that arraignment
to deliver remarks.
He will be there at Mar
a Lago at his resort.
And I am told by sources
this will be the former
president's opportunity
to really take control of the narrative.
Of course,
we have heard him
from the last several weeks
calling this a political witch
hunt a hoax.
But this will be the first time
that we actually see him
respond to the charges
as we all learn them on
Tuesday afternoon.
That's what we're expected to
actually learn what they are.
All right.
Christine Holmes, thank you
there live from West Palm Beach.
Let's go ahead and dig deeper
into the security concerns now.
Joining us is Jonathan Wackrow.
He is CNN law enforcement
analyst and
a former Secret Service agent.
So you know this
like the back of your hand,
except this is unprecedented.
Let's talk
about what's going to happen here.
Usually the Secret Service is in charge
of presidents, former
presidents, vice presidents,
and they're the ones that sort of make
the plan.
Is that going to be different now?
It is different now.
The Secret Service is not the lead
coordinating agency for this.
The security protocols
that we see being put into place, it's
actually the NYPD
is taking the lead role
along with the New York
state court officers
They're really bifurcating
the internal security of the courthouse
and then external in the city at large.
And that's unique for the Secret Service.
Typically, we do see them in that lead,
coordinating role,
whether it's for political
rallies, presidential events.
But this is different.
This is a private event.
This is private business
that the former president
has to do in front of the court.
So from the Secret Service standpoint,
it's almost administrative.
Their responsibility
is the protectee
bringing him from point A
into the courthouse,
allowing the former president
to do his business before the court
and getting out all safely,
but very well coordinated
with other law enforcement entities
who are
who are participating
in tomorrow's event.
I am curious
how long it has taken
for them to coordinate,
knowing all of this
that has been happening
in the lead up to this.
But I do want to ask you
what their concerns are.
I mean, there are a myriad of things
that could happen
when you have a city the size of New York
with the speed at which New York,
you know, flows.
What are the big security concerns
that they should be looking out for?
Really, you have to think about.
We've known about tomorrow for a while.
Right. We anticipated it.
So law enforcement
has been coordinating,
putting together security plan
the overlay of the city.
So not just at the courthouse,
but the city at large.
The challenge is addressing
the wild card events.
What happens
if there's peaceful protests
that actually turns into,
you know, violence?
What happens?
It's consequence management.
But the NYPD
does this better than any other law
enforcement entity in the world.
They're prepared.
Tomorrow you'll see
35,000 uniformed NYPD officers
in a 24 hour period,
making sure that the city is safe.
And secure.
They're going to play it
extremely cautious. Why?
Because law enforcement
no longer has to anticipate
whether or not
domestic violence
extremists will actually engage
We know from January six that they will.
So they have to overprepare tomorrow,
prepare for the worst case scenario.
Hope for the best.
Hopefully it's peaceful protests
individuals
expressing their First Amendment
constitutional right.
But it doesn't transcend into violence.
And we know very similar to January six,
you were hearing
from the former president,
he is
calling on people to
to be there to support him.
I do want to ask you about this sort of,
you know, mandate that every agency has
and everything is political
at some point, right,
when you're dealing with
a former president.
And certainly he's made it
so posting on social media.
So when it comes to Donald Trump
and when it comes to the Secret Service
handling this particular unprecedented
historic case,
how do they do it
without getting sucked into the politics?
Well, listen,
there's no other law enforcement entity
in the world that's drawn into politics
more than the Secret Service. Right.
By the nature of their job,
they're at the White House.
They're with political leaders.
But this is a seminal moment
for the agency
where they have to remain neutral.
The optic has to show
that they're not currying
favor to the former president
nor the D.A.
They need to focus
on their primary remit,
which is protection
protecting the former president,
because that's
what they're mandated to do.
They work with other law enforcement
entities to ensure
that the area is secure,
but they are not coordinating
any special accommodations
for the president inside.
The moment that they do.
They'll they'll be swayed
one way or the other.
And right now,
it is essential
for the agency
just to do their core
responsibility of protection.